rubén lanzó un globo con agua al aire y
registró su altura con respecto al
tiempo desde que lo lanzó gráfica los
datos en un diagrama de dispersión
tenemos aquí los datos como tiempo en
segundos y altura en metros aquí vemos
esta gráfica en el eje de las x
normalmente se pone la variable
independiente que en este caso es el
tiempo y en el eje de las 10 ponemos la
variable que sospechamos tiene una
relación o depende de esta variable
independiente y es la que ponemos aquí
en el eje de las 'íes' en este caso es
la altura vamos a ubicar cada uno de
estos pares ordenados en la gráfica el
primer par es cero en tiempo cero
segundos y la altura 1.7 metros tenemos
el tiempo cero y la altura 1.7 que está
más o menos por acá muy bien nuestro
siguiente paso tiempo punto unos
segundos la altura fue de 1.85 vemos
punto 1 segundos y la altura 1.8 1.85
está acá
o menos el siguiente par puntos 2
segundos y 1.9 metros punto 2 segundos y
1.9 metros está hasta acá más o menos un
poquito más arriba el siguiente punto 3
segundos y 1.85 metros punto 3 segundos
iba a 1.85 ahí está el siguiente punto 4
segundos a 1.7 punto 4 subimos punto 4
aquí en nuestra variable independiente y
subimos en el eje y hasta nuestro valor
de 1.7 que está aquí siguiente punto
punto 5 segundos a 1.5 metros punto 5
segundos en el eje de las equis y en el
eje de la yes 1.5 subimos subimos
subimos
y está más o menos por acá siguiente
dato punto seis segundos aquí y la
altura 1 punto 15 puntos 6 de altura
1.15 está más o menos por acá tiempo
punto 7 altura punto 7 subimos subimos
subimos punto 7 está por acá el
penúltimo punto ocho segundos apuntó 35
este sí estuvo bajito nos queda punto 4
está acá punto 35 está por aquí el
último punto 9 según 200 metros de
altura debe estar acá estos son los
puntos en la gráfica que corresponden a
esta información vamos a ver qué tan
bien lo grafica vamos comprobar
respuesta correcta esto estuvo bien